oh this is yours I've got a story about
a girl who like stun guns on a clip as
well as the clip person yeah stun guns
on it click are you ready for this
Wow Shawn welcome back to the podcast
show lose your now twerk thank you very
much for coming out man yeah for Wall
Street I give you that nickname
I mean undated with true grd gang
followers Twitter YouTube yeah you do a
lot of like talks at night at schools
and all that's odd anyone who's seen the
podcast boys feels now on the light we
saw you Georgie that's [__] awesome
this thing in the schools your podcast
kids love it and yet you still swear
every podcast [__] off if you don't like
that's my attitude so yeah good good
again I'm back on me second time round
we didn't really call out everything
that there was to cover last time y'all
say you came in a little bit blind last
time you don't quite know what you're in
for
yeah and we had a great chat it was
awesome so yeah weird we'll start that
how's it been since I last seen you just
doing endless talks got my book out
about the Cali cartel just uh an
american-made is the best soul as well
bestseller yeah got that is that Tom
Cruise movie or George Barris he'll say
cocaine flying pilots did you put
anything about not about the hand George
senior being a dirty little man in there
oh yeah there's a whole chapter on
protecting pedophiles about George HW
Bush oh come and talk about that now so
wait there is they're really old chap
because we all know that in the Elite
levels of government
there are peters who being protected and
it's being exposed in britain recently
there in america there's a lot of video
theories on youtube smiles
perverts Pinos pervert a bit of
everything [__] I mean all subhuman
scum
I mean well because you're a bit of a
pervert but you're not speedo known the
horny Buster but there's a big
difference isn't it let's be honest a
good point a shoe off a fully-grown
nicely well developed women right we all
know that I can still be a perv and just
say so what did you find when you
started researching about George W
George HW this book is about who killed
Barry seal and the to lead suspects are
Pablo Escobar and George HW it was Bari
seal he was he worked for the CIA he was
flying arms out and cocaine in to
America all with CIA protection there
was a movie out about him Tom Cruise
Vegas I'm cremated yeah last month yeah
so I had to do a complete analysis of
George HW Bush's life on the last
chapters is about a senior Republican
politician who was part of a sex ring
where they were flying these kids all
over the country Jesus and they even had
on the rage rentboys in the White House
and then when it came to the
investigators we were looking into this
because the kids are coming forward and
complainings kids are getting snatched
from some boys home and the guys who
were investigating it got killed and the
kids the ones who were the victims they
ended up getting prosecuted and put in
prison and it was all completely
silenced I was in the press room
they say that Jimmy Savile one of the
reasons he went protected for so long
and not was because he was providing
children for his royal members and all
that he was trying to help people don't
get those now so I read Princess Di's
book in our own words know what is she
say respect the dead
due respect I when's she and Charles
having problems marital problems who did
they bring into counsel huh hey jimmy
savile the royal family bringing jimmy
savile a DJ I mean this is a family that
if you take a foot walk there's a cause
he does all the running it'll make a
feel okay so this is a family if you
take a photo of them you can't even
speak to them because their royal see
huh yeah a DJ Jimmy Savile was brought
in to counsel died and she said she left
that meeting with very creepy feelings
about him yeah I'm here access to the
top levels of the royal family yeah sure
whoever thinks she's feeling a bit down
about things we we have access to anyone
in the world nor the royal family and
you go unlimited budget yeah I'm limited
you go something we've struggled lately
did you know this seriously yeah you got
you know we've got unlimited budget we
can get anyone did anyone who would fix
princess I'll give him a good 20 minutes
like - cigar smoke at the front door
Diana don't bring him in here that
affects [__] anything yeah I'm
already [__] one pervert what what
evidence did you find that suggested
kids were around the White House and all
that where did you find these things out
there's a woman who's fired campaigned
tirelessly to expose this because her
kid got snatched on First Street in
Nebraska and years later showed up and
she went on the TV and everything trying
to find him and years later showed up
and he said here's what here's what
happened
I was kidnapped I was taken they had at
gunpoint they forced me to have sex with
a person they filmed it and then I was
turned into a male prostitute and just
flown all over the country - it's a VIP
clients I mean it's nothing for
follow-up question that the well I've
heard about this before in great deal
because there was some politicians who
were high up in America who were
prosecuted for this but it stopped
before everything led to George
everything has pointing the finger at
him and when you see videos of him what
do and there's also videos of who was
Barack Obama right okay Joe Biden did
you see in the videos of him I've seen
I've seen one video of him which makes
him which makes a long it's a long video
with multiple children where as the
children are coming up though amis very
light and all in all of this and he's
touching them very inappropriate and
he's whispering in deloria and it's it's
the least amount of evidence yet still
leaves you feeling creeped out as [__]
when he watches and and everything's
being pointing to people like George
Bush for years but he's never being done
and he never will be less to be honest I
did write about Bill Clinton here as
well and he settled multiple rape suits
and his brother Roger was arrested for
dealing cocaine yeah yeah so you're
saying that and Bill got his free card
and didn't he let's build it he said how
come people more people don't speak
about that sort of I mean they're
supposed Donald Trump did speak about
that quiet a lot of my research has been
based on ex-cia whistleblowers right and
those guys when they came out and said
stuff alternative media wasn't very
strong back then did pick up on a little
bit but the mainstream media just came
down on them and just you know all of
these stories are saying these guys are
completely bonkers this is untrue blah
blah blah yeah what going about and
looking at all the police reports and
everything you see you can see it's
highly documented yes let's just reading
up about it now literally it's there's a
lot of if you google it but by the book
by the book it's going american-made and
I'd imagine that also sort of put a lot
of heat on you in a way didn't it
because if you're printing this sort of
thing that's a book that's then a
best-seller and up this was a best
seller on Amazon
yes it was just a lot of people must
then look into Bango who's this Sean
Apple guys printing big hooks about he
defiles interest in the money google it
yeah former US President George HW Bush
this was 25th of October this year has
apologized after an actress nearly 60
years as jr. accused him of groping her
from his wheelchair Helen in 34 Bush 93
yes still got the urges at 93 going at
it I think you helmet he so they his
office released an official station up
in a photography exactly what his
explanation for that is that he has I
guess like a degenerative thing or he's
older now and so he can't keep his arm
I'm not hoping this is really saying is
that actually his arm drops down
apparently and sort of often to this the
height of a woman's literally would have
to he's got restless arm syndrome I
think as a symptom threats only groping
the block is for a long time being
called it just a disgusting human being
I think also after a while people start
to look evil don't know when they when
they're more that people speak about MS
evil people they're more they start to
look evil Tony bear looks evil people
have read this and the reviews of saying
George HW Bush was a far more evil
person than Pablo and I asked them may
see that Pablo's responsible about 4,000
to 5,000 deaths
Wow wash over 100,000 in three wars and
a few miles around
yeah but then Pablo is much more
directly responsible Bush was much more
of a sort of circumstance
yeah and patriotism and you know I know
and all the other [__] as this put
any heat on you in any way there's
people's anyone followed up a lot of
people saying it's great and they like
they love it
the people that don't like it saying
it's conspiracy theory stuff I don't
believe it but I think a lot of people
waking up these days to what's really
going on in the world so that's why
things like this is taking off how can
you how can you sort of print this sort
of thing without someone coming along
and saying to you try to show your
photos well I've got my own publishing
company site I can print whatever I want
yeah and if anyone wants to come and say
it's untrue come and sue me yeah yeah
because obviously if they then sue you
good all the times like well hey it's
good advertising but be yeah guess it's
also that that if it is true it's very
difficult Susan yeah yeah yeah great
well come in what you say oh yeah yeah
yeah for some reason when Sean says
something I believe it which is and I
was watching the podcast back and I
thought he told so many stories that if
someone else told that I'd go back a
couple of times I quite enjoyed some of
your stories and I remember thinking
that's how my [__] but I did leave
out my father's new thing
well sickly story though which in in the
next half hour you're gonna find out
what Sean has to say about his
hardest-hitting story join us after this
good to know to do that bollocks well on
this morning was it awful Sean was it
that's what they do on the Sonos it was
a really sudden juice chug at issue do
you want to cry so these all part of
because obviously they're all similar
artwork and these are part of a series
these are my war on drugs series there's
gonna be four books so I've got three
out right now what's the fourth we are
being lied to the war on drugs and is
that a present-day so I think these are
obviously here's it's gonna go back 150
years give the complete history of drug
laws yeah how the corporation's came in
to me weed illegal to protect all the
industries and how that's led to this
monstrous prison industrial complex were
you got all the races and
blacklivesmatter on us stuff that's gone
on today it ties into one of the
questions that came in on you guys is
Twitter yeah but he said what stock
market stuff you invested in there
you guys asked me that last time yeah so
it wasn't invested anything haven't made
my move yet well I have just made my
move this research actually could you
should we stop and then I'll get in on
this and they're Canadian cannabis yours
right yeah because what were happening
now is full legalization in Canada yeah
first of July next year right
California nationwide yep California
fifth biggest economy in the world full
legalization previously you had tobacco
alcohol and pharmaceuticals put enough
money to keep the drug lost site and
demonize weed last week you had one of
the biggest alcohol companies
Constellation Brands Wells Corona by a
10% stake in canopy growth which is the
biggest of all of the Canadian Canada
mushroom isn't having that buddy yeah
smokin Ajay even having a corona die
getting faded so the cannabis industry
now is on the biggest fastest growing
industries in the world it's not that
big yet what they estimate is going to
go into the tens of billions so I've
analyzed all these Canadian cannabis
companies and I think you could make 10
times your money in the next five years
I've already invested in two of them
myself
mm-hmm Wow because I see as it hits the
market people are gonna start buying it
I'm gonna see these other companies like
the alcohol companies tobacco
pharmaceuticals start to bide mistakes
in these companies yeah this was the
legitimization of the industry last week
when the alcohol company made its move
so they can't fight them off any longer
there I think they've realized that
we're beating here whether we try and
fight it or not people are going to do
this I also think sometimes they leave
it into a certain time when they just
think this is our next stage what are we
going to do next
let's do cannabis beer it's the
investment opportunity of a lifetime
because the end of a black market yeah
we've never seen anything like this yeah
and if you've researched this and
there's thousands of industrial
applications this isn't about people
gettin blazed this is you you can make
anything from surfboards to cookies yeah
from home
and then all of the medicinal family
uses as well yeah cancer everything yeah
yeah so incredibly that's what you're
investing in my that's what I'm a memory
well I write I'm gonna be a millionaire
again in five years Wow partially
through this oh I'm so sorry nobody
follows asked as well best book on the
stock market yeah
it's Stan wine Stein's secrets for
profiting in Bowl and BRR markets ball
market is if it's going up a better
market is when if it's going down so you
go along when you're going up you go
short when it's going down you bet you
sell it before you buy it right you buy
it back at a cheaper price yeah
so I've read hundreds of books on the
subject I bought this woman when I was a
teenager in America and Stan was my idol
and when I did work my way up into the
stock market he started to mentor me
over to fall yeah this lease until the
Norden two questions coming on your
Twitter and they said we got business
advice for young entrepreneurs yeah so I
say whatever field you are interested in
find someone who's at the top of the
field yeah if they've got books out read
them try and contact that person if you
can't contact them if they won't get
they'll speak to you try and copy their
business model
and then you've got you know you got
sure you have to make all the mistakes
that's what I did
it's true I think having someone to look
up there was a really good idea good
advice I having someone older someone
that's got some of that experience you
can listen to because you will make
mistakes along the way anyway yeah it's
only you naturally part the process by
having someone who can sort of reward
you away from the massive mistakes or
silly mistakes is a good thing what
annoys me is when people aspire to be
like someone and they go I want to be
like that guy and and they're not
willing to go through the same things
I'm like you're you're just a [__]
lazy prick at this point and I know so
many people who say they idolize so
people then they'd say I'm gonna be like
them and they don't put the work and
people cause of me every day well every
week sorry and say
I've got a story can you just write my
book and you know I've got this great
story bla bla bla and then I know I say
what's involved it's only ten years of
sweating blood to write my own life
stories a trilogy and they don't want to
put the work in they thing if you've got
a magic wand and you can just make them
rich overnight yeah it doesn't work like
that how many loads of flakes to be
honest I got a lot of flaky people
messages yeah I want to do this I want
to do that and the minute you start
telling them what's involved in it
they're just bottled Java straight away
what was also interesting was a similar
situation happened with Michael Jackson
and Paul McCartney and Paul McCartney
told Michael Jackson buy the rights to
songs and Michael Jackson bought all of
the rights to the pickles for the
Beatles and Paul McCartney's song yeah
and ironically Paul McCartney lost a
load of money because he gave to me
failure I think we all know who won in
the end of yeah called pedals yep George
HW and MJ
sure I think McCarney but he's not no
he's as far as we know definitely not he
likes women a little bit too much cause
that did cost accustomary man quite a
bit I've just interested here what you
were saying about young entrepreneurs is
there anything else that you would
advise them in cuz I mean as someone who
wants to start businesses myself or not
I wanna branch out as much as humanly
possible yeah is there any main mistake
you think that people make when they try
and do set businesses up and things like
that hey mistakes I think like I said
early find someone who's done successful
things and learn from them but also like
you said you've got a balance that
output the working stuff but you also
have to make your own mistakes
like in the stock market quickest way to
learn stop Mike is lose money
all the kids rather right now they've
got these trading accounts online
without any money they're just like on
paper and they think they can trade the
stock market because there are a hundred
percent and then you ask me at the
skills are like forget about that
account put some money in and see what
happens
it completely changes your psychology so
you gotta go out there and have some
real world experience definitely is a
big thing put in a lot of time and
effort into learning your craft I was
told
reading would improve my writing so I
read over a thousand books in just under
six years in prison even as a teenager
when I first got interested to stop mark
if my teacher was giving me classes on
my own I went down the library on my own
and ordered dozens of books on the
subject just tried to learn everything I
possibly could
I thought the stock market was a numbers
game it's nights crowd psychology
so it's both there's a lot of good books
up that's what everyone's gonna do now
yes I could be pretty good at that I
guess stretch reading trends as well how
people packed
yeah like Bitcoin right now yeah that is
crowd psychology go back there's a book
called extraordinary popular delusions
and the madness of crowds by Charles
Mackay and he documented the tulip bulb
mania in Holland centuries ago people
are emerging their houses and elephants
by chul-soo the calls were more valuable
than gold and this thing completely
crashed you know the majority of people
lost everything I've done listen to the
last podcast so for anyone who hasn't
already worked out obviously we've had
yard before yeah you were a young
entrepreneur who had a love for the
drugs and and of going out and all of
that became very successful in Arizona
made a lot of money and then started
getting further and further at the
tropes and of getting locked up one
thing we didn't really talk about is and
not as much as I want you what it was
like from the moment you got released to
sort of where you are now because you
know the videos are on your YouTube
channel which I'll link in the
description below for those watching
where you sort of you're on your way out
with your family out of America you're
sort of looking at cars and you're like
so much has changed in 10 years you know
be a text and now we're in text and when
you went in and things I thought yeah
what was it like rehabilitated yourself
and getting back into just normal life
what the phones
I'd banned phones people I was using
PayPal to do my calls because the tops
went before I got arrested obviously the
cops can trace your phone and all that
kind of stuff so I wasn't hip
it's a texting because I was stayed away
from phones so yeah my sister was in the
car and she was just showing me how to
do all the texting and stuff and in the
prison I've been writing it down I said
yeah you know for getting on a computer
and writing mortifies me I'm just gonna
write all my work down and keep going
like this slowly slowly I got on the
computer and got a Microsoft Word and
now I'm on dragon yeah it took me ten
years to write my life story it was like
this dragon dictation software pumping
our free books a year it's great what is
them yeah be a family after everything
you've been through they obviously know
that you're not a normal guy yeah how
now is that you're talking in schools
and you saw a lead and a good example as
opposed to the way you did live your
life how do you think they view you now
one of the questions that came in was
about the family side as well and I
can't remember forgot into that very
deeply last time but my mom I was
blessed in the beginning cuz I saw so
many people get this song by the family
members cousin involvement in drugs in
prison and that was blessed my family
came 5,000 miles a year to come and
visit me out in the desert and wait for
hours on end to get in the jail and the
guards are rude and stuff like that and
so yeah I was that that was one of the
things that helped my mental health and
helped me get through it was was the
strong family support
there was a sensationalist newspaper
story came out about me to wait two
months after I got arrested it was in
the phoenix new times it said english
sean's
evil empire it was ten pages long so it
was everything I did and ten times more
and they portrayed me to be cross
between like Walter White and a vampire
so I called my hands in Arizona I said
don't let my mom see this you know the
my mom and dad a gentle people is gonna
break their hearts I said it's too late
John as an Internet version so my mom
read and she had a nervous breakdown she
was a college teacher
and she read it and she ran up to some
students and she started yelling at em I
know you've read the article I know you
know what's going on they didn't have a
clue what she was on about so my dad had
to get her and you know I got to live
with this the rest of my life the effect
on my mom my sister had counseled them
it's like oh I do talks across the
country and it's almost like I can still
see the hurt and pain on their faces
that have caused them yeah so how do you
feel about what only it's making me
really sad talking well Syd yeah yeah
yeah this just disgusted himself
basically do you think something you've
ever sort of managed to square away in
them all right
I do the talks in the schools now it's
the positive thing that's come out of
this yeah and in the beginning my moment
that was supporting me and coming to the
school starts cuz my mom said when I was
in the house for like the first six
months I was like a puppy dog just
falling around the house waiting for
orders because I was institutionalized
I've done this interview on a BBC and a
guy concepts BBC and gave me the
opportunity to speak in the schools but
I was like a year and a half before I
could get my head straight to do a talk
now in the beginning my parents did come
to some of the talks with me just out of
pure love and support but then they
stopped and they didn't really say why
boy they didn't want to be reliving it
yeah yeah so they don't they won't come
to my talks anymore but they see the
effect its had on the kids my mom even
got up impromptu at the end of my school
I went so I did a talk in my hometown
witness and they said so where would you
get on speech and she was a bit
uncertain about it what she did and she
got up and they all started crying the
kid started crying teachers were crying
everything it was like my mom started
crying and that was it and she was up
there about 10 minutes the videos on one
of the videos is on YouTube that would
that I'm sorry that was the one YouTube
is in Stoke Newington
she spoke as thought knudsen yeah yeah
yeah and I have the kid after him -
teacher show the kids that video as well
she'll have to show the effect that it
has on the family if you're getting
involved in drugs you know you're
invincible your young person but when
you're in prison and your families
visiting you're worried you're gonna get
killed and raped takes its toll on them
mmm yeah what I was wondering is like
just generally I know obviously it was
awful for what your family went through
because they do seem like sort of
wholesome people and that and you were
totally different in that way you push
the boundaries have you rebuilt
rehabilitated that relationship to a
point where you feel like things are
pretty okay now I feel that they're
proud of what I'm doing now but also in
my heart it tells me now you pop through
this thing that was so tremendously
shocking to them that's something that
they'll it'll be in them for the rest of
their lives and so that's that's what
keeps me okay
it keeps me motivated to do good as well
you know like kids since I say would you
go back to the lifestyle and I wouldn't
because I've got a strain from my
Anatsui but another thing that helps me
is I'd be selling out the kid to talk to
and I'd be selling out my parents I
think maybe you could quit your
celebrates luck as well no because you
know a lot of people have made mistakes
yours just happened to be more costly
than the average person's yeah and
nobody's nobody's perfect they're not it
says it you know you're a good person
because of how much that hurts you
yeah because an [__] wouldn't even
think about how much they've hurt other
people or anything like that I know a
lot of people who rationalize things bad
things that they have done but you're
not rationalizing that you're not
cutting yourself any slack to me like
one thing I'm thinking though which is
pretty good is the fact that you said
that your mom worked with kids and now
she's saying you so I'll follow in her
footsteps in a way yeah just be nice for
us yeah that's that's nice for her my
legal fees were 100 grand mmm because
you don't get out I'll be still be in
prison if they haven't come up with that
money and they're not rich people they
remortgage the house and cast in a
retirement account
they were close to retirement my dad had
to continue work you continue working
after his retirement because of because
of that yeah hate yourself a little bit
yeah
stuff like that bloody is hot at it like
yeah what happened to the money you know
after everything went tits up and not
because you said that I think you'd
[__] a lot of the money away through
playing the stocks in your actual
business yeah and then the drill man you
drew when he came in what happens when
you get arrested and you've got all this
cash did they just take a lot okay they
want target people who've got money the
police and so they can get it I guess we
cycled back into the police department
who get more gadgets faster cars
surveillance equipment and I was stupid
enough to put myself in that situation
so absolutely everything I made was
taken mm-hmm but flawed people out put
money in their names cops at the virus
in my computer showed him where all the
money was I mean their sensationalist
newspaper story said I was flying out my
granny in a wheelchair yeah people like
people with canes and wheelchairs and
you could put millions of dollars of
cocaine in the in the rims of the
wheelchairs and stuff and in the canes
yeah it's amazing really isn't it it's
funny because I met someone recently who
was a pretty I'd say
enjoying and their me specifically and
and they were talking to us and they
were like because they were like you I
just feel like every worry in the
world's being lifted offers and and all
me confidence comes straight away and I
feel so full of happiness and love and
it was I [__] how like it's like
everything you said about it cuz I tried
to perform me life by hours and [__] me
like everything it just it's getting
approved in America now for PTSD mm-hmm
Jesus yeah I'm gonna use it on the
troops but and that makes sense because
of the effects it has but also while the
downsides of it like what what - calm
down joke on it and stuff all right
the downside on ecstasy in the beginning
it is there's not much actually you know
when you first thought out as a young
person and I just wake up next they
smile and still yeah but what happens is
every time you do drugs that pleasure
goes down slowly over time so and it
happens so slowly
a lot of people don't notice it but they
are always chasing those early highs
they want them to come back so as you do
your system in it does get rougher and
you know the way we got around that was
xanax I mean by the end of it we were
partying on ten different drugs at these
raves and after parties on the weekends
and then we take xanax anti-anxiety
medication puts you to sleep and you
just wake up as crisp as a baby it's
funny because the average person who I
may know who was taking stuff yeah
they've got the worry of can we afford
things that wasn't an issue for you of
anything that was like a [__] buffet
well yeah it was the way you described
it because you had that many contacts
who wanted your stuff and you were got
their stuff and then we served the
uppers a buffet as well in our after
party joint we took all the paintings
down in the villa and then just bought a
different pile of drugs on each painting
and had it like as a buffet served yeah
by the girls yeah yeah and so did you
feel a great loss for all that money and
all that stuff all right
first year in the jail I was still wild
I've quit dealing before I got arrested
but I was still going out the weekends
getting high so first year I would have
gone back to the lifestyle I was
planning for it back
English Sean his character in the scene
but my second year when they told me I
was facing their 200 year sentence and I
was pushed to the brink of suicidal
insanity I was going to just slash my
wrists because I couldn't take it
anymore in
it crushed out on me and I credit now
getting to that point his stress and the
tension as a turning point I started to
see the needs of other people instead of
my own selfish party needs once I got a
sentence a nine and a half years it was
one the happiest days of my life because
I could see when I was gonna get my life
back all the material [__] didn't matter
anymore because you'd given up on that
on the 200-year certain so yeah years
because about why do you think it is
that people cuz I feel like I'm a little
bit I identify a bit with you in the
sense I've had quite an extreme life and
I've had a yeah how are you talking
about it much but I've had a few moments
I mean those without being like rock
bottom as they say yeah why do [__]
like us have to go solo to learn those
lessons and other people can just stay
within the bow do you know like just
some people like bowling balls and they
just bought it right down in the middle
and may have no I hate all the pins but
whereas people like us we have to go we
have to go right off the trucks and
[__] gold medal because we're
thrill-seeking renegades most people
prefer to stay in a comfort zone but we
know it's a double-edged sword because
that can lead to huge success because
you're a risk taker but it can also lead
to SWAT teams and holding on tightly to
that soap in the shower I always had
that fear when I was growing up like I
thought I'm going to end up doing like
time like I had a feeling and I've had
many dreams where I'm in jail like but
for me being locked up is a it's not
prison that I anything like that and I
hear prison stories that yeah obviously
they're not great when you hear these
stories like the ones that you've got to
tell but that's not what frightens is
about it at all it's the lack of freedom
yeah they're not being able to walk and
do whatever occurs maybe in such a
pigheaded bus that who wants to do
everything his own way yeah being told
everything what you can do what you can
do all day every day would [__] kill
me it's suffocating in the beginning but
you've gotta get used to it cuz it's
like banging your head against the wall
yeah you're just gonna hurt yourself
unless you just deal learn to go with
the program yeah
it's not like it changed elements of
what you thought by yourself quite a lot
you know the intrinsic identity that
you've got but it changed the way that
you saw your own identity oh absolutely
it was like I had to look inside myself
when previously I'd just been rushing
through my life yeah you know a lot of
people just living a fast paced life
particularly here in London crime they
don't take time for introspection but
what prisoners they were start to review
their lives and look inside themselves I
forced that rat reflection forces you to
change
it's funny how for some people prison is
like a godsend in some respects because
it makes them do what they should have
been doing the whole time
flexible is holding a mirror up to your
soul yeah but she's not my something a
lot of people some rich people paid to
go away on meditative weekends to have
mirrors held up to their soul you think
that present could be a much healthier
place to be for something not really not
really because I because of all the drug
use that's what something is actually a
lot of people a lot of people get in
there and they get into the wrong side
of things you different you're like an
empty cell for example feeling that sort
of thing should should be good for you
but because of the way that the system
setup is set up the people to go to
prison to lose essentially yeah because
the prison wins when you lose yeah when
you get re-arrested for your drug
addiction which we're not going to help
you with we get fifty thousand dollars
of taxpayers money per year yeah thank
you very much exactly yeah and when I
look at your life when I was thinking
about that the day on the way down like
one thing I admire is people who evolved
throughout their lives I feel like so
many people loved me I'm like you are
the same [__] person at 10 20 30 40
50 you're like they're just some people
don't change whereas when you describe
how you where as a young teenage on how
the lack of confidence and all of that
and I don't even know how on earth you
went through so much of a change and now
will come out on the other side of it
what's it being like to go through so
many changes in that respect Shh changes
that were forced on me and as a result
of my bad decisions and 1's
for me to grow like previously for over
ten years that I just lived for the
weekend it was like I could hear the
wolves howling for me to come out to the
rave scene and now I feel like I have
changed but I've got this wolf inside me
but I've got it in a cage and the walls
like it can pay some side two sides of
the cage but it can't get out when I
hear the music and stuff and I get that
excitement you know well I've got all
these techniques that I've learned from
the therapist and from reading
philosophy and psychology that have
helped me get all that under control and
I'm mature as a person have you found
writing quite a cathartic process
absolutely the lessons I give I've got a
life lessons talk to schools another
final lesson is about taking time for
introspection analyzing your thought
processes how your brain works your
shifts in emotions stuff like that and
an ideal way to do that is by writing
you if it's a blog or just a thought
journal or just a personal diary because
over time you see you how you mature as
a person you look back you think oh that
sounds silly now I was immature back
then and you also see your shifts in
emotion so for example you know I was
diagnosed as bipolar and I was in denial
about that and then my therapist in
prison he told me to keep this thought
journal and I wrote an entry down when I
was manic mm-hmm and I look back when I
was calm down oh my god you know there's
something there's something going on
there I'll just read it to you real
quick
so this was in prison when I wrote this
overwhelmingly inexplicably happy feel
as if I can accomplish anything I've
written for almost eight hours my mind
is racing with ideas creativity and the
right words are flowing naturally I
haven't showered done yoga or talk to
anyone other than uh shoeing a few
visitors out time is flying the
announcements of Rek beginning and
ending a two-hour period seemed like ten
minutes I thought I was hearing stuff
when wreck ended because time couldn't
possibly go so fast I've accomplished a
lot today I'm extremely satisfied
in comparison to recent happiness and
way off the scale why can't I feel this
good every day I feel I could walk to
the chow hall and back on my hands and
maybe even fly
so just to pick up off of that yeah how
do you think that sounds when you read
it back to yourself now why come on
speed or something so my dad has also
got bipolar disorder yeah and he often
writes things and he writes things that
sound exactly like that
yeah and out and I'll read them and I'll
think like as well I class myself is a
little bit of an extremist but yeah but
mentally I'm on an even keel and I'll go
very high and I never go very low yeah
and I pick up on those amazing highs and
lows of me and some people who have
bipolar I find anyway they fall in love
with that illness because it's a little
bit like a drug bipolar from what I'm
gathering anyway yeah and in those
extremes become addictive to the point
where some people don't even want to
medical it themselves for they rather be
in that in the bipolar July mean do you
I do take medication for it they tried
to put me on the medication over the
years and I've got a good story about
the mental health is different there's
there's different extremes of bipolar
disorder isn't it because I know my
dad's was a I mean it seemed pretty
[__] extreme at one point to be
honest with you yeah how would you what
would you class yours us less than my
mum's cuz my mom has been on the verge
of suicide and stuff like that and she's
out to get on the pills quite hardcore
and I've run the pills on and off but I
find the pills stymie my creativity
cloud my mind and I can't focus on all
my goals and stuff like us off I've
ditched him quite quickly so in the
prison
I'm thinking this is like mental
hospital anyway in here you know and
it's gonna make a lot of people behave
crazy and think crazy yeah and on the
pills what it was it was okay to be on
the pill somewhat into prison for me but
when so when I got out then I go back to
my hometown witness and you know I'm
telling the doctor and stuff what was
all the pills was on and I said well I
feel sane now cuz I'm out of prison this
was a situational madness because the
place was just so mental and they said
when someone who's got bipole and they
think that they're normal and they don't
need to be on the pills then we actually
feel not sure not sure you shouldn't
just be on the pills we feel we need to
double your dose right now right that's
what they said to me and this is what if
you said I feel mendel give me more
well the bandits have welcomed it and
I'll get to that one of them with you so
double D dosage if they double the
dosage I'm taking it home I've got no
money back man you know I'm on the
dollars stuff like that I'm supposed to
be taking these pills for income support
and my uh what we're gonna do so then
they start saying we want to do blood
tests on you to see if you taking the
pills cuz I'm started to flush him down
the toilet and stomates realize they
were giving me and then they wanted to
do home visits and then they were friend
into section me so this was at my mom
and dad's house for a year this was all
building up and then I move down south
and my medical file didn't transfer I
never heard from again brain just just a
question because I think this is quite a
blessing the people at home would be a
blessed Norris
what was it like when you did take the
tablet and why did you not want to take
them all right the gossipy points in the
prison where I wanted to kill myself
because of it because of the conditions
of offenders nice attention yeah we
remember how horrible they I couldn't
sleep as well that's one the work she
can't sleep yeah and yeah once once it
cut once that calmed me down
then the asite then your staffing in our
ad side-effects
that's that's what that was the cycle
with me so I never stayed on for long
what side effects was that anyone so
imagine like just they like make your
pee a lot and they make it like nausea
sand you sweat in and you're shaking a
little bear and you trying to get you
the right words on the right words like
we're now it's like your brains really
slowed down all these kind of things and
everything that makes you you
is not that type of guy isn't it yeah
yeah erection this direct is one why did
manager still waxham especially with the
dick lifts we were doing there and we're
a lot of people in prison on those drugs
then I guess oh my goodness is a whole
industry I think the military is the
biggest buyer of prescription pills in
the US and I think the prison system
which is enough shoot at the
military-industrial complex is another
one of the biggest buyers so in areas I
was house about 2/3 of the prisoners
would line up at pill call and you see
them doing what's called a Thorazine
shuffle well you know they slowed down
they're just coming in shuffling towards
the pill nurse so it was this like
Bulgarian shot put of a pill nervous
isn't open your mouth like they're
putting them the pills in funky places
in their mouths because there's a whole
black market for the pills yeah you know
you could trade your pills for all kinds
yeah yeah we've seen their programs I
mean I mentioned 60 days inside of you
where they put regular people in prison
and the CCTV every day look at and we've
seen them hiding that pills and sniffing
them and doing [__] - yeah but I was
just thinking you know like going back
to the bipolar and things that obviously
that's really helped you and you in your
career in a way yeah because
you're creative and then you want to get
everything out there and your minds race
and at times in terms of like going back
to just being a regular dude who because
you obviously did another missus when
you come out or did you know have you
got back there like are you just going
out with women and he sent me that idea
previously I've mentioned who have been
going out with and I've managed to get
stalkers online for the women right okay
yeah so you didn't mention all right so
yeah you you've caught back to a normal
life so that's a normal life yeah yeah
on the mental health thing just real
quick because one of you people asked as
well about mental Health's cases in then
on what what's do to improve it there
was a guy I met call Slingblade right
this was in a morning Nick Miam that is
security prison but what he did he was a
Vietnam vet came back from Vietnam vet
his head all messed up and he killed his
had a flashback and killed his
father-in-law yeah so he got he got 25
to life but he was eligible for parole
now when I met sling blade so in medium
security you can go out with like two
hours onto the REC field a recreation
field so everyone files out the building
the gun to the rec field and people are
doing like sports pull-up bars dip bars
and stuff like that and everyone's in
the various cliques and then there's
just this massive guy like like the size
of a sumo wrestler
no one's going near him and he's just
looking up at the sky and he's like me
he's good killing one we like this yeah
he's drooling at the corner of his mouth
yeah that'll probably not make you want
to go over there
that's a do you pronounce it snapped on
a few people and like just you know
sauce big and strong I am just like that
so in the beginning I gave him a wide
berth like everybody else oh the other
thing was as well because he was so
biggie on this big appetite so he roamed
the chow hall like you know you don't
disrespect people taking the food and
message people's to put your fingers on
people straightest to fly that's that's
you're gonna get in a fight this guy was
so crazy
he just roamed the chow hall grabbed
when people were put in the Charles like
there's 100 guys file in and there's a
big hole like a trap in the wall where a
tray comes out so you can't see the
other prisoner so you can't get what's
called homie hookups where your homeboys
can give you extra stuff yeah so these
trays just come out trays just coming
out everyone gets in sits down you got
like 15 minutes to eat so sling baby
gets his and he eats and they just start
looking around the whole of the chow
hall and then anyone who's taking the
food back there's another hole that you
put you you stray in well you know cuz
it's garbage you know a lot of food gets
thrown away so you'd be like almost
about to put your hand to the to the
hole on this big I would just come
speechless for her
but if you know gunnies on table then
wait 10 trays leftover trays I think me
and Slingblade modernity no guards were
fine without they were just so like let
him eat well what can you do let me see
the question yes pause well I gave it to
him then throw it away so alright anyway
I'm interested in extremes of people and
this was an extreme that interested me
definitely so I first started out I
approached the omen from a distance by
just asking people his story in his
history in the prison that's how I found
out what he's done and I basically
starts go up to and start to talk to him
and he would say things normal things
but then he say yeah the you know
they've got the Hope Diamond waiting for
me in California and when I get out I'm
gonna buy a house with the Hope Diamond
and everything's gonna be alright and it
was really stuff so he was just going in
and out of reality and it got to the
point where I was giving him peanut ba
and crackers and he would come to my
cell and what do you do nod when he come
to my cell he like fill the whole cell
up and I give him some peanut butter
crackers and he tell you know I'd start
talking to the stove and then he just
turn around and leave we're all saying
goodbye and I'd lock out and like all
the prisoners that seem coming and just
all the robbers just get out of his way
just walking down the run now John
McCain Republican politician Vietnam vet
had a bank of abroad app about his he
was a prisoner of war yeah it was his
plane went down and the other captured
he was he was run against Barack Obama
when he won the president he was
dropping poison on Vietnamese kids
basically from his plane that's what I
was told
Wow he's dying you know I did all that
kind of stuff he's dying of cancer now
isn't he is it John McCain I think so
okay yeah well I contacted him because
he says he helps Vietnam vets yeah his
sling blade he was eligible to get out
he'd done his sentence right
he was so mentally ill he could not
facilitate his release because he didn't
have an address to go to
so I contacted John McCain offices of
John McCain explosively they held
Vietnam vets and they didn't do
absolutely anything for him and then I
research later on John McCain was one of
the biggest beneficiaries of political
contributions from the private prisons
in Arizona part of the clique yeah yeah
sadly I got a letter last year
Slingblade passed away he'd done about
seven or eight years past the time he
could have been released mmm
what do you do with her would you put
him in a mental hospital awesome
was the thing I had another guy no it
was a legal eagle he's like a jailhouse
lawyer hmm he was on the ball never and
and he was helping me with legal legal
stuff to try and get the way pay for
Slingblade to go somewhere safe because
his idea was yeah it's what it's it's a
humanitarian thing to get this guy
released what happens you know if he
does something well the consequences god
yeah I'm just hung in there oh yeah come
in and they're walking with the train
and sling yeah it's crazy isn't what the
one thing I would like to talk about is
making a murderer yeah you wrote a book
about that yeah can you give a quick
sort of summary for anyone who hasn't
see in the Netflix Shore about kind of
what happened it what what we know and
then what your theory is
yeah about what the real story was okay
cuz I don't know the difference right
now with evidence why it's been a while
since I watch it yeah so before making a
miracle now I was ranting on my blog and
about the injustice of the u.s. systems
no cuz I got injustice because I deserve
what I got
well I saw the horror of all these
prosecutors all the dirty tricks they
played on these people why is the rest
category when I was busted was young
people with weed usually just fraud
black kid in the are Mexican kid
forgiving five years for giant waste of
what made me sick just to see what was
going on filling all these private
prisons so
aha and when making a murderer Kemal
when Netflix premiere just over a year
ago oh well just lit up this outcry
about these things that I've been
reading about mmm so far I'm gonna put
some videos online because people are
gonna want to help these guys they're
gonna want to send them things in prison
by item things right to them you can't
just send a letter to a prisoner you
know people hundreds of letters got sent
back because they hadn't put Steven
Avery's prison number on the envelope
right all these rules you gotta follow
this was you know I started my dad
started my youtube channel when I got
released almost ten years ago and it had
like a thousand this Orphic followers
like up to about eight years ago making
a murder come out I put these videos on
my youtube channel and my subs were
jumping like thousands mmm and all these
responses from these people all over the
world that wanted to help these guys
send them letters send them money I was
putting all the procedures down there I
got in touch of the family members and
stuff uh-huh and before another good
thing I can do is write a book about
these guys the profits from it gonna go
to charity half of it has gone to so far
it's called on making a murderer and
half of its gone to the lawyers
representing Steven Avery and Brendan
Dassey
and the other half has gone something
I've set up where I donate books to kids
in state schools and prisons my thousand
more books just a job come in yeah so
yes you know what what what happens
these guys what are we officially know
like provable evidence and then what
your theory is about the Steven Avery
so if 18 years for an attempted murder
and a rape that he hadn't done hmm it's
a fact that he was exonerated right so
it was it was proven that this other guy
that the rapist called the Sandman who
was attacking women his DNA and his
her pubic hair was found at the scene so
when DNA testing came around they were
able to prove this event beyond the
shadow of a doubt and the Sandman he's
doing time for it now
now the Sheriff's Department picked on
Steven Avery because Steven Avery had
some criminal history and he had a beef
with a wife of a deputy sheriff so if
the father I'll be will just get him in
so even as evidence came to light about
this man this of a man who 18 years
after Steven Avery being inside they had
ever discovered the evidence they're not
did they know the evidence from day one
some of the evidence they knew from day
one it was hidden the DNA testing came
much like a science of progress here so
all they could do was say that the her
the pubic hair was a reasonable match to
Steven a which they did because they
brought in an expert and the expert will
say it whatever the state was a blond
blond
yes yeah yeah with a reasonable degree
of scientific certainty
it's his yeah yeah and the jury's gonna
believe somebody's got a big criminal
history or this but he's got a glasses
and a lab coat on songs done on the show
they do it and this is one of the
trusses in my doors box is pay expert
witnesses to lie yeah it's called tester
lying it's so common in America so some
of the staff of the prosecutor's office
the Sun man had been being surveyed by
the police and they said it's not a
breeze to send man and the sheriff and
the prosecutor said to their own staff
we've contacted the Sandman's probation
officer and he's east told us that the
Sandman was with his probation officer
on that day it's completely I just made
it up to ship the ranch showed up there
on work for us for me yeah yeah so
nothing happens to them because they've
got absolute immunity from prosecution
so 18 years later they found out he's
innocent they hold him in for about
another two years in the late mouth he's
about to receive 32 million in
compensation the first check from Milly
a million our stories on the governor's
desk and then trees a howl bat goes
missing
you're gonna blame a guy who's about to
get 5 million because she'd visited him
that day and she was a photographer mmm
all for the comment for the car so yeah
yeah so they got him they pulled him in
he was the suspect right away about any
evidence and they pull them in and then
they kept changing how he'd killed her
why he'd killed her one of his alibis
was his nephew Brendan Dassey who also
was arrested who also was arrest in his
presently still inside Brendan Dassey
his IQ I think was like 60 so in the 60s
or something like that one's best it
they snatched him from his high school
they told him he could go home and watch
WrestleMania go back much Wrestlemania
if you just come with awesome and that's
all these questions to repair that's
pretty good offers in the title fight
miss Alma so after they interviewed him
for hours and hours and hours and it's
heartbreaking I've got these videos on
my youtube channel and basically they
wanted to say that he helped Stephen and
he and they shot
freezer in the head so the two
detectives saying what did you do to her
head Brendan and this guy like hardly
says any front of any times he's just
like he says um we cut or her you cut to
her what did you cut of her with is just
like make your fingers up you know it's
still the official version now is that
they caught her before they did also
because it just maybe this is maybe it's
putting her up next we punched her where
did you punch you in the face they want
him to say they shot her in the head and
he's going it's like a guessing game
basically and in the end they say to
brendham
who shattered who shot her in the head
Brendan just again to say yes Oh Stephen
dead you're joking because he just wants
to give the right answer so go watch
WrestleMania right
[Applause]
they they essentially get him into a
point where he feels like he's giving
the right answer as they so long Terral
I was in you know getting interviewed
and someone said they just got to see a
lauren shot someone so I could go watch
Russell Banyan really yeah yeah because
I remember when then when it was said
that he was gonna be released
one of the main comments in the articles
was because it was right before
WrestleMania WrestleMania yeah you'll
finally get to say it and you know us
what the update is this is just gun his
case is now gone the trunk in front of a
five judge panel and the prosecutor got
up there
this isn't this guy he's like the new
clip one of the new Ken Kratz and then
brendan dassey's
attorney lauren not narrator she's
absolutely brilliant she spoke from the
heart
yeah I've seen her in division she's
grating but the judge roasted the female
judge roasted the prosecutor in the
beginning and she said look this is I
watch this this stuff with Brendan
Dassey and it made me sick you basically
just having him doing a guessing game
now how can you how can wasn't one shred
of DNA evidence saying just to show that
they took her to this bedroom raped her
tighter to the bed tortured her stabbed
her in the belly shot her in the head
did only sickness there's no teen
evidence at all anyway yeah there's
nothing linking Brendan Dassey to this
crime other than his old confession he's
the biggest victim of in this whole case
after Teresa because Stephen at least
had some criminal history do you think
that they're just in a situation now
where that so much has gone on and they
can't to save face they've just got bury
these two if they let them out this
opens the floodgates use all the
wrongdoing such as the state crime lab
and all of the prisoners that have been
convicted by these same prosecutors in
the crime lab of Wisconsin are they
gonna be able to sue these guys the
floodgates we're talking hundreds of
million
if not in the billions it's all about
money they all let those guys out
because not just still have to pay them
money but they have to pay money to
everybody else
the who's gonna but when these
floodgates open which inevitably would
happen it but you never said what
happened yet because there's then this
president American so you've got the
federal court system now Kathleen
Zellner Stephen who'd using shot the
woman though you got anything right
zelner has filed a huge motion which is
over a thousand pages long and she's put
a lot of evidence in this motion
pointing towards the ex-boyfriend Ryan
Hill against hmm he apparently had her
day planner and stuff stuff that she
took sister when she went to visit the
every property they could tell by the
pings from the cell phone towers then
steeper that the trees are left the able
property mhm and Hill a gas was jealous
because she was doing some sexy
photography hmm and she got together
there was a couple she's done some sexy
photography for and she'd actually got
together with the husband
and she'd also got together with someone
that Ryan but the ex-boyfriend new as
well so he was building up this jealousy
now that's one of the possibilities
I had a possibility submitted to my book
which was the two people on meth perhaps
did it because the crime was so savage
you know to stab her and burn and do all
these horrific things the savagery
someone perhaps on meth or the boyfriend
they would like an emotional crime
doesn't it was usually someone you know
or the ex-boyfriend specifically
something that that's yeah not bad yeah
it's interesting that obviously you talk
about your interests in mass psychology
are you just as interested in kind of
the individual side of it because
there's a lot of interest at the moment
in the psychology of a murderer and most
sort of thing and mostly frustrated by
all psychology yeah
well the biggest genres of books I read
were psychology in the prison then I
went back and read all the original text
you know by Freud Jung from all these
different because you read the textbooks
and they're just interpretations of the
work yeah but it's brilliant to see how
psychology xiv although there is in
neuroscience now
is one of the areas that fascinates me
the most yeah one case I've just been
watching on Sky recently was called the
murder of Laci Peterson where she was a
pregnant woman in half months pregnant
goes missing and her husband's just out
fishing for the day gets back she's gone
and there's a lot of evidence that says
she may have been out walking the dog
there was also right at the same time a
burglary in the area yeah and people
saying that she might have tried to stop
the burglars anyway she goes missing and
the family Orfila where is she where is
she and the husband never really
appealed the same way as but he's only
guilty of not appealing as much as the
family did and being a bit more
withdrawn anyway it turns out he was
having an affair and two weeks before
his wife went missing he said he told
the girl who was having an affair with
on the phone got the recorded tips oh
yeah me this is my first Christmas
without my wife and she hadn't went
missing yet so a lot of people are
saying that's like he's he's a
clairvoyant or you know he's working out
a way of not being there for Christmas
or maybe but all these provably guilty
of is having an affair yeah but when it
was proven that he he was having an
affair and the weird things he said in
the way he acted
basically he was convicted of his wife's
murder his wife's body did kind of show
up in us and not too far away from a
position yeah but there's no physical
evidence there's no physical evidence
that he actually murdered a lot and yet
yeah they still got him on a on a murder
conviction oh yeah I mean they've got
the most money the state hmm and it's
the court is a theatre show mm-hmm he
puts on the best performance wins in the
confession tapes there's a guy who him
and his wife in the front of the car
three daughters in the back
accidentally there's a malfunction the
car and he goes off a bridge I want to
talk to you about this right
but so what do you think about this
because and this was on the confession
tips program yeah the dark net flix the
mom and dad veer off road and the crush
through like a barrier and going to the
water all the kids died and the parents
survivors three kids in the back was
gonna yeah do you think that was a
deliberate thing job cuz they grilled
him didn't the follow us how many I was
like afterwards they blame his behavior
saying he look he looks guilty he's not
reacting right but he was in shock the
only thing that made me think there was
two things I found very strange about
that yeah they kept the car so the car
that the children died in they retained
and kept using it enough for me
yeah basically driving around the coffin
of your children at that point like that
that really baffled me but maybe money's
tight I don't know but I wouldn't you
wouldn't keep the car and that was a
weird thing and also there was a lot of
dispute between was there a malfunction
that wasn't proven that there was a
malfunction yeah so it was his word
lawyer said they had over examples of it
how do their examples but it's one of
those isn't it it is a weird one it it
strike did the car things weird here the
car the keeping the car struck strikes
me as strange I often think people's
behavior is a bit of an unusual one
because it can sometimes be a bit of a
red herring where people are well
they're not reacting in the way that
very often is they're not reacting the
way that I want me yes your textbook way
deals with death you're gonna kill it
kids
are you gonna they're in a way that you
could possibly die as well well this was
this was the thing that I kept thinking
to myself is I'm in the water I'm in a
car
yeah I'm me three cows you do miss me
three children are in the back yeah and
I'm at that moment where you've got to
try and save everyone as the yard
especially you have to think of it like
that your responsibility to get everyone
out alive the woman gets out alive
I don't know how deep the the car was
but I'm sitting there trying to think of
myself as far as I'm concerned as a man
yeah if I'm if I
making out there alive it's because my
kids have survived and I'm gonna go back
underwater and hold myself underwater
and keep trying to get them out with
till I breathe in water myself yeah so
at the very least I looked at him like a
coward for coming out of there alive
there are guys that are died diving and
if the dogs out there all the time
people dive enough to strangers kids and
try and save other people's kids so
they're not even I thought meself I'd
rather have died trying to save me on
Kate and then did it with some really my
thing if you're going in headfirst in
the car and say your front window pasta
or something are you the door was open
your door was open and that the shock of
what was going on he's jeopardizing my
side everything's happening so fast I
agree if you see so you see a dog fall
in the water I could just go too deep so
deep enough it happened so fast it's
gonna be a bit different I agree but I
also think and not being a father myself
but I guess the my I imagine my instinct
would be the kids no get out you know
well there may be at the same time you
think well you know it's only a safety
belt it's only a seatbelt the kids can
get out and then you know but you know
you'd still think that there will be
something is what we're trying to look
at this from a logical point of view as
well as if you were going to kill your
kids how would you do it and therefore
if I think to kill your own child is the
most unnatural thing to ever think of in
the in the world so in order to do it
you're not gonna think logically for a
start so that was a really hard case for
me like if did he get sent down for a
stolen yeah yeah have you have you been
watching mind hunters about the FBI when
they decided to sort of take a shift
towards psychology yeah I never seemed
quite cynically the FBI but it's quite a
it's quite a neat story I don't know
it's obviously all fiction but it's one
thing it's based on the idea you know
sort of when the FBI began to upgrade
their ideas of psychology and those
sorts of things and some of it is it's
quite interesting it's obviously huge
parallels but today because in some of
the cases the
psychology gets wrongly used against
someone or a friend indeed
it was you know guy or justice can't be
served because someone's already done a
deal somewhere else in the case so if
they go against the psychology rather
than yeah those are things it's really
interesting to see how before that
people just thought of criminals is good
and bad but also how it's a commentary
also on how some police do still see it
that way a lot of pet people almost deny
it they're like this person's bad and
this person's good was a criminal no
cripples what P those murderers rapists
a criminal nails a young person getting
pasta with a bit of drugs that's the
vast majority of minimum yeah exactly
yeah there's a really interesting gauged
it brings up a lot of social ideas as
well as how crimes change dependent upon
the the social times and those are
things like you know apparently
different crimes will change depending
upon who's president dependent upon
those sorts of things in Greece yeah
well that wasn't a crime back then that
was much much more the right house yeah
yeah I don't even freaks me out that
[__] yeah do you know what I do find
really unless and what I find myself
watching a lot of kids who killed like
documentaries yeah cuz that really mean
the Jimmy Bulger case of 17 years old he
was looking bathed by his mom that one
oh and he was a narcissist see you often
find that there's death there's signals
like that we think you still get made by
his mum it's always girlfriend he was a
professional tennis player he was gonna
play in a tournament in America and
you've got his money off his dad's
account to fly her out there and take us
to this tournament and it was it just
made it a lot and even the house he was
hammering on the wall his dad asked him
about the money or something for the
flights and stuff and he just took the
hammer to his dad's head and
Bam Bam Bam Bam and then through his mum
as well tried to stop it I blamed the
Beatles did you kill them both kill them
both yeah yeah there's one story of a
hammer in recently where I think was
like a 15 year old lard at school was a
bit of a loser and became friends with
the 11 year olds and he would've hung
around with those kids yeah and I think
he tried to touch one of the 11 year old
boys and he was like what are you gay
like in and he just freaked stabbed him
to death hit him in a [__] wheelie
bin or something like that and the whole
area are out looking for him and
obviously his DNA is or like his mother
came about that there was like what's
all this red marks on the carpet that
he'd cleaned it up as best he could but
don't see a bad job and it just makes
you well know like after all people born
evil no okay just know I wrote a book
it's up it's not published yet about my
mate - Tony's it protected me in prison
that's the gangster isn't it 141 years
like uncle Jun yeah and you know he
covers his entire childhood and his
parents used to say to me the basement
will whip him and his mom just said I'm
gonna kill him just took a turkey fork
in his neck yeah so he said I don't to
make excuses for my crimes he says I
take full responsibility but when you're
a little kid and these kind of things
happen to you it doesn't make you into
an aggressive [__] well you have
to be too much what happens what
happened I believe in born evil oh
really
I do I why the Jimmy Bulger one made me
believe in born evil I'm not saying that
those two lads who did it
had a great upbringing by any means but
when you're that young and you're
capable of that kind of murder I just
think that that actually made me think
the devil is it as a real thing like a
junkie the doubt like it's so evil that
it's almost like this is like next-level
Schiller's see I think this is like
spiritual [__] evil I know like
that's an excuse for people I was born
evil I feel like that's a really easy
way it's just that it reaffirms people
shitty beliefs about inherent
evil and good you know that I don't know
I feel like that just it allows people
to then put that on over this example
that person is I know I'm not even
thinking about what other people think
or our belief systems I'm just looking
at this one person and thinking
obviously I believe no but have you had
enough of even the experience life to
even have a bad life enough to commit
something like that without being just
evil
well surely then there's so much of that
you just said they had not the best
upbringing was like I don't do illness I
guess also it's different I think is
probably different for kids as well
isn't it a murdering child that doesn't
quite know the consequences of some of
the things they're doing there's you
know kids are still playing games when
they're kids you don't really know the
boundaries one of the kids in school who
were like they would just hit other
people may thought it was a game and
they had no idea what they would do yeah
but if anything you can look at it the
other way which is which is also you are
capable of a lot less as a child yeah
yeah if anything yeah I was at my most
friendly in my life as a as an 11 year
old kid I was at my most harmless that I
did I was least capable because I had
the least amount of knowledge of the
horrors of the world and in kids aren't
thinking about those what they did I
don't always think that kids know about
and now you're looking at it with an
adult brain looking what a child's done
and that is horrific imagine if and I
don't I've done that I think kids do
things and they don't quite understand
the consequences what they're doing well
I agree with the consequence of say two
things but but what I mean is the horror
of some of the things that we see in
children child killers do in the past
yeah is more severe but through the eyes
of a child than the eyes of say for
example at 16 years old I worked in a
butcher shop and I'm just boom boom boom
saying flesh being smushed a bit every
day I'm desensitized to the other so the
father then is a 17 year old lad go and
whack someone with a meat cleaver
I'm not gonna be as frightened to do
that I'm not gonna be freaked out if I
need blood gets on us yeah whereas if if
I was to say those things
an eight-year-old it would it would
freak me out even more because it's like
what the hell is this I'm just a child
I'm not used to this general I mean I
think like that's your identity that
you're put in another people though
because we had a kid in school used to
tell he's coming to school and used to
tell us when I'm older I'm gonna have
sex with that girl and we were all like
we were like eight or nine and we were
like what and he was like err and we
were my dad and I sit at home and we
watch sex videos I remember being like
that like that there's something wrong
with that
yeah that's really really popular and he
was I when I'm older I'm gonna have sex
with business and everyone in class was
like that's really weird but no one
thought it was evil it was just like
he's just he's clearly had really
unknown and watching palm if your dad
your dad once
look at that like yeah definitely yeah I
mean the guy realize now company's a
classical violence but he went into
music it was I remember at the time even
his kid you know the difference it was
so clear that you always know the DAAD
so it was so clear that he didn't know
the difference that the killer in saying
this was something this is a fun like
I'm talking from a visual point of view
watching someone die through a child's
eyes I think is harder to handle than
through an adult-sized and that's why it
shocks me more when children do these
things I'm interested I'm interested in
why people do get fairly fascinated with
murder I understand it's something
that's fairly out of the ordinary
and you know there are aspects to murder
and drugs and all those sort of things
then feel quite exceptional yeah do you
know that do you know have you ever seen
a murder are you well I saw people in
the prison just get carried out look
like they were dead on stretchers en
garde the yellow stuff coming out of his
head Jesus and you don't know if the
dead are lives all the family members
who to jail later on yeah yeah
but so what led you obviously you're
sort of X your fascination with the
extreme probably was part of that as
well there's it is unusual though murder
is unusual it's become something that
seems to be quite mainstream now what's
all over Netflix isn't it it's hell suit
yeah what what what's your idea as to
why that sells and do you Trey you do
get too dangerous
so many people are watching these type
of programs and normalizing in a way and
getting a buzz off of them I call it
Senora of science when something
horrific when we see something horrific
happening this goes back to the
prehistoric times when the threats were
chasing us our brains released a certain
chemical yeah which excites us and makes
us remember this more than anything else
we're gonna remember mm-hmm this is why
it's so hot to get rid of these traumas
so the brains getting activated by the
sight of the horrific thing so if it's a
murder or whatever a brain remembers
those traumatic experiences so clearly
as opposed to a happy memory
yeah John all the people slowing down
there's a car crash someone's being
killed on the road love a blast the flip
your brains like whoosh yeah it's up its
resolute happens to me I've gotta pay
attention and it also in that attachment
also then attaches something which is
quite unreasonable to that memory as
well so someone who's been through a car
crash would then think well next time
I'm in a car I could be in a car crash
and that's fine I'm reasonable yeah and
and I guess that we're going down that
path of psychology now where instead of
sort of just constantly talk about just
people's emotions there's things like
CBT and things like that was try and go
to the root of what that thought is and
wonder that why that happens yeah it was
your therapy based on that and what's
the terrible numerous purpose and I did
appreciate CBT yeah cognitive behavioral
therapy which means you can control
things with your reactions and your
thoughts yeah so if some you know if
people picking on you you don't have to
react to it you can tell yourself you
know I can walk away from this situation
I'm not gonna like it we'll get that
person locked me into the energy hmm
that kind of thing because it is CBT I
think a lot of people find CBT quite to
be quite an effective form of therapy
yeah on a daily basis as an pills
yeah very often for a lot of people yeah
and also I mean I some people get sort
of locked into the pills and before they
can find the therapy unfortunately for
them and before probably do the therapy
they're into pills and it's very
difficult to get off maps yeah
did you did you ever find the other way
that some people were very encouraging
of you getting on the pills and very
encouraging of you being a bit of a
victim of your entire well situation for
various reasons some of the medical
stuff in prison apart from public
practice right prisoners are considered
human beings as institutional use yeah
we can experiment on them with the
latest generation of psychotropic
medication so that's what they're doing
here they were really trying to get you
to do vaccines get pills get everything
in there yeah I was lucky at the end of
it because this one therapist dr. o was
into neuroscience Eastern philosophy he
knew I was reading all these books and I
would just go in and discuss quotes with
him but people say to me is the mental
health services and there is it good and
I say yeah it's more focused but the
rest of it was bad and they say well why
all the people getting help from this
therapist because there's a prevalent us
versus them mentality they feel if they
if they say anything to the therapist
it's gonna be used against them in the
future
yeah which is again makes it difficult
to comment venerable can't be horrible
yeah which is an important part of
opening up banana can't move all the
walls all imprison you one thing that
you said you were going to tell us at
the start was just the worst thing that
you've seen in your time in prison yeah
what was that this is the most horrific
disgusting thing I mean I felt ill just
reading my notes on the way here oh my
bro it's not it's quite a long story
oh no we've got all day man he cries so
in the last podcast and we discussed my
friend my 6 and 1/2 foot trans friend
Xena Xena yeah what a name is waldir
worry worries me so no really it is a
quality name because it puts a mental
image straight there doesent yeah so
Xena was a
mamaan but live living out was a woman
so I was inna belief she is a woman
trapped in a man's body
right and I mentioned last time that she
was horrific Lee gang rape they stuffed
the broomstick in a backside and and
raped her while she was unconscious and
she started plucking people's eyeballs
out to stop it yeah [__] me that is it's
the way you the way you described that
last time I remember like wow I it's not
something I'd like to have happen to me
like you might be thinking that again in
a minute - inna got up - right right so
I'm just gonna describe this as inna
telling me through a letter that she
wrote what she did in prisons this is
her life this is her words yeah and you
had correspondence obviously yeah she
writes to me once or twice a year
something like that and for some reason
tells this story because it's a very
important story that every one of the
worlds are here yeah yeah yeah all right
I removed all of my clothes and
straddling the toilets
I grabbed my scrotum with my left hand
and with my right hand I cut the right
side of my scrotum about one and a half
inches long the pain was minimal blood
began to run down the inside of my thigh
I glanced into the toilet and saw a
steady drip drip drip from the wound I
placed the razor blade onto my table and
reached into my scrotum with my thumb
and forefinger I grabbed my right
testicle and pulled it to the surface
the next step was a little more
difficult
cutting the inner layer of tissue
surrounding the testicle itself
remembering what I had read in the Mosby
medical dictionary I separated my testes
with my left hand using my thumb and
forefinger I placed the razor at the top
of the cut and buried the blade about
1/4 inch into the testicle itself and
began to cut down the testicle came
easily out of the skin
and with great amusements I realized
that there was no pain holding the razor
blade between my teeth I grabbed one of
the rubber bands from the ball and I
tied it around the spermatic cord below
the spermatic bundle of my right
testicle I cinched it tightly still no
pain maybe it was adrenaline that was
keeping me from feeling anything
or maybe hyped with all the thinking
that this would be so painful which was
just not true I grabbed the razor from
between my teeth licking my lips I could
taste the blood on the razor I placed
the blade directly above the cord about
1/2 inch from the tied rubber band in
one swift motion I severed the testicle
from my body then holding it like a
fisherman would a minnow
I dropped it into the toilet and flushed
I looked to the ceiling it was the very
first real moment I felt pain oh [__] I
screamed the pain welled up like a hot
arrow stabbing my abdomen pounding it as
if it were tied to a jackhammer Coffee
was no suitable painkiller it did not
work when I was passing kidney stones
five years ago which was the worst pain
I've ever felt the pain which shot into
my body was way beyond the pain a kidney
stone could cause the room began to sway
my eyes were losing focus it was so
intense I felt this was all I would be
able to do of course I was wrong I set
the razor into the soapy water bowl then
I began to breathe inhaled one deep
breath exhaled over and over until I
regained my focus I was not going to be
defeated by pain it was no match for my
mind looking down between my legs I said
one down and one left to [__] off but
did you finish the job
we're always against ties I reached back
into my scrotum and found the left
testicle residing where it ought to be
and brought it forward to the wound in
my sack one small problem
Mosby's medical dictionary never
mentioned that the testes were wrapped
individually from one another and there
was a divider of thick skin separating
the two of a roadmap of blue and red
veins crossing one another throughout
this section I had two options one let
go and go through the other side to cut
through the middle and hope for the best
I opted for two grabbing the Rays that I
began to chop this skin however was a
whole lot softer and hurt a considerable
amount more I don't know whether it was
the cup of coffee or the superstitious
feelings which were bombarding my mind
at that moment my hands began to shake
violently
I had trouble concentrating I put the
razor back into the water and let go of
what I was doing I stared at the ceiling
for a long moment I did not want to
believe the events which were
accumulating it was not going my way I
began to breathe after a while my hands
felt a little more steady I reached into
my scrotum and began to pull the
testicle to the opening word to my total
horror the rubber band tied to my right
spermatic cord came loose blood sprayed
from inside my scrotum all the way to
the back of the bunk five feet now
things went from serious to deadly
I felt for the very first time a panic
rushed from my head into my belly to my
extremities I shook violently my mind
was preoccupied I heard the
glug-glug-glug of blood in a steady flow
from my body flowed from the wound of my
scrotum into the toilet like water being
dumped from a plastic jug into a pool of
water son of a [__] son of a [__] I
kept saying over and over
I lock down between my legs and fought
about just how long it might take for me
to bleed out the blood was a steady
stream from my body to the inside of the
toilet I reached back and flushed
I watched the wall to fill the bowl and
realize the water was already so full of
blood that I could not see the bottom of
the bowl I grabbed the wound in my
scrotum and squeezed it shut I was
worried that I was not going to be able
to complete the job too much bleeding
way too much bleeding I stood up and
went to the door
I pulled the sheets away from the door
and looked out of the window no one was
walking around the officer in the tower
looked as if he were asleep I moved the
shower the sheet back and went and
flushed the toilet as I stood there and
watched the ball fill up with fresh
water I resolved in my mind that I
needed to hurry up and cut the other off
quickly after getting it I pulled it to
the surface of the cot and held it there
with my left hand the bleeding was
enormous and I began to feel faint
I grabbed the Rays out before cutting I
glanced at the clock 2:30 p.m. I've been
doing this for 40 minutes at least 10 to
15 minutes of heavy bleeding no wonder I
was feeling faint cold chills were up
and down and throughout my body shaking
these thoughts out of my head I began to
cut again except now my nerve was shot
and I was afraid I was going to die I
did not want to die this was not what I
was trying to accomplish all I wanted
was to get rid of the body of that nasty
hormone testosterone I wanted to feel
like a normal person one step closer to
being a woman I didn't want to feel what
it was like and then die because I bled
out the testicle slipped from my grasp I
breathed out heavily I was exhausted and
frustrated I was afraid that if I were
not able to finish the job I would never
get the chance again so I reached into
my scrotum yet a game with my right hand
god dam where the [__] is it I exclaimed
as I shoved three fingers in as far as
they would go into my scrotum I was
searching around
and could not find anything which
remotely felt like the left testicle
which must have swam away inside my body
somewhere slipping my little finger into
the wound I shoved my whole hand up
inside my body searching frantically for
the elusive left testicle I could hear a
comedic news report inside my hand this
just in xena the prison giant s trying
to feel more feminine opted to remove
her testicles using only a razor blade
pulled from a disposable razor during
the attempt the other one decided it was
enough packed its bags and left for a
vacation insider the medical term for
this phenomenon is retraction however it
is our belief that given the fate of its
neighbor the other ones desire was to
hang around for the rest of her years
rather than swim into this longer septic
canal like its departed partner is doing
now I shoved practically my entire hand
through the wound in my scrotum looking
for the testicle at one point I could
feel my bladder and there's something
large and squishy which I believe was
part of my intestines fed up I stopped
the search and began instead to look for
the severed spermatic cord where my
testicle used to be i searched
frantically for almost a minute and then
resolved in my failure i looked at the
clock it was 240 i removed my hand from
inside my body and began to bawl up
toilet paper and shove it inside my
scrotum i patched the cot up with more
toilet paper
I named my creation the bloody van Gogh
of toilet paper stuck ol nutsack I stood
up on shaking legs and went to the door
I removed the sheet from the door looked
out with the window and
all for help Wow you like your balls so
that's gonna be a really I just kept
thinking [__] love my balls yeah
doesn't let you go right to your own
balls doesn't it no it just makes you
appreciate them a lot more general I
mean so it was an attempt really that
that was a holla to survivor big got a
helicopter [__] me but wouldn't I doubt
she would have died and then she was on
suicide watch
and then she waited and then got the of
one of what winner blade again clearly
they cauterized the wound with a
cigarette lighter I mean I've got no
idea what it feels like to be a man who
feels like a woman trapped inside of
that put man you know like what yeah I
mean how long has she got inside 30 plus
she is [__] Oh actually she stands at
10 or less nothing mm-hmm cuz I was
thinking yourself wouldn't it be easier
just wait until you got out but I
suppose that's not really an option in
hearing there I've done it successfully
cauterized the wound one anew in there
done it and the ruined had got rotten
and she got busted because she rotten
way and she was hospitalized and then
she got in trouble but she looked like
most like a woman however anyone ever
seen in there yeah it was you no no no
this a friend of Zeena my first day in
prison and I'm like who's on who's the
lighter were they were in the sauna it
wasn't considered game mmm cuz Donna's
got no nuts
she's trans mmm we decided we're a trans
person goes whether they call in a woman
to present our mantras in Arizona
literally gender it's what your bomb
with right so I just got a letter from a
prison gender right
this a Mexican gangster me in prison
called Frankie he was like a mexican
mafia hitman it done
29 years when I met him he beat there he
was in for murder-for-hire be that case
cuz all the witnesses had disappeared it
was a big big sound chess champion and I
know he's been reelected he's back in I
just got a letter from him cuz he's
bisexual he's really frisky and he was
hitting on me all the time and stuff and
trying to get me to play strip chess but
he's just found hermaphrodite in there
he's like you're in life every option
gone yeah yeah spoilt for choice of
anything yeah it must be an unusual
experience to go into prison in the
first place
how do you now feel about the overall
justice system that's what the questions
are coming from one of your people as
well I think the justice system is going
has been hijacked by truly evil
politicians and corporations that are
making money off predominantly young
people getting busted with drugs it was
weed yeah then they took it to the
extreme of in America and that's why you
got the decriminalization at the state
level that's the people voting against
the politicians and against all this
thing it's not the federal government
prisons are for pedos murderers rapists
serial killers society needs to be
detected from them but the media put all
these headlines out saying this is what
prisoners are extreme criminals to keep
the public [__] themselves whether
you run your average prison is a black
kid or a Mexican kid getting busted for
small amount of drugs and what's gonna
happen when weed is decriminalized in
certain places because obviously
there'll be some people who went away
for crimes purely because a weed it's
gonna put the police and the churches
and the lawyers and the private prisons
out of business that's gonna save the
taxpayers billions that's already begun
in Colorado and they're taking that
money and giving the kids drugs
education
because I was thought of Colorado is a
particularly conservative the first ones
to change at California Colorado first
ones
and cut I guess Colorado is more of a
libertarian state than a democratic when
it comes to weed apparently yeah
presently sixty something percent of the
public in America are for weed full
legalization which is majority majority
brexit even bigger number for medicinal
use yeah you got this this is this kid
over there who gets she keeps getting
hundreds of seizures and they can go
into comas and dies these kids yeah
and now if it works from conventional
for Pihl company's I think I named
Charlotte right and they're using this
case now Charlotte she's on the cannabis
oil and our seizures are down all these
of a states now are using Charlotte's
case to get medicinal introduced what do
you what do you think of Louie theories
documentary on drugs in America did you
see there's a recent one but don't worry
someone yet just want to just come out
Lee it's coming over that last three
gone cocaine was there you saw that I
thought it was going to be a bit
different than what it was I hope he was
actually littered nor did you did you
siap I mean honestly yeah so basically
in the first episode he describes how
one of his friends went on a cocaine
binge and then ended up dying through
jumping out of a building something like
that happened um and he really said
either one that happen again so we're
gonna go and check how many of my
restaurants have exposure I call K and
he's dubbing them down in everything's
coming back positive basically like
everyone is on the [__] here and he
goes to say how are the cocaine's made
and that I did find that really
interesting because like he thinks of
how does at least become a white powder
and you think it'll be you wouldn't
expect it to be the way that they
actually do it and how many chemicals
actually used in the middle of it in the
second one he sort of went back to his
restaurant and I thought it's gonna be
like a few part series and he didn't he
did see some of their like crime at
involved in it but at the end he sort of
goes by it was a restaurant and he's
like right so don't any of youse do
cocaine anymore and I was like
this is corny this meant like you know
if you want to do that in private but it
really felt like it was dry every
employees got to stand outside and watch
him give this amazing almost Braveheart
speech and it sort of got a bit like
you're just doing this to make yourself
look good a little bit and I don't think
he was but that's just how it was shot
yeah some TV shows doing then a really
sort of [__] way yes
what's his conclusion gonna me what
Calkins really great actually well don't
do it anymore
yeah but that's it was a little bit like
it was almost like right but how do we
end this then just get a ton of these
employees that if you uncork you can
come and we'll set you up with a
counselor yeah yeah I mean throwing him
in the neck where they gonna get I did
think that the lowest I thought lowest
throws one so he's bouncing back after
Scientology because I thought that was
no way yeah and his 100 was was pretty
good because it showed what the current
situation is and like a part of it like
I know how it's used in like pimps I use
an it's of the getting the the who guys
addicted dish and then they just make
sure that they keep them addicted do it
and then yeah they're on the game basis
it's all illegal so the gangsters have
got control the markets they're the
government mmm do you ever think back to
that time with all the prostitutes and
all those people and sort of feel
differently to the way that you feel
felt at the time but feel differently
well you must feel differently now
obviously looking back at that sort of
feeling ten different drugs I mean I
sort of you're looking back and you
think well you know you were using
prostitutes who are clearly involved in
drugs at that time I started saying yeah
the moral yeah it's morally wrong is
what happened with us and striptease
dancers and prostitutes so that they
would come to the parties wouldn't need
to let the her down and get and have a
Raven's right in the console our after
parties and stuff so
not justifying it so you're saying is it
was their choice as opposed to you it
wasn't like we're gangsters really like
you [__] comment and yeah that's not
a party and you say if you want to come
come yeah they hate their customers
stuff and they come to us and they think
we were cool and they were hang out with
us
so yeah let's do some of the crazy
behavior now on to clitoral piercings
what was that all about
remember the last story I told you about
a woman I got married with on the Las
Vegas Strip and you're in a you're in a
room the prostitute you know you didn't
come she was she a part lesbian porn
sauce he was doing lesbian into the
apartment Amazo yeah yeah
this is the woman before her right yeah
the other one different one yeah yeah so
the first one was the crazy one there
was some girlfriends in between as well
do you had the first wife was a the
ocean agent one that tried to cut my
balls off you second one a good hunt so
the second one video was that was the
second one but lesbian porn star per se
the third wife was the lesbian porn star
in the middle what was she because she
was a former mother I think it's a meth
and right that's right yeah she actually
got clean in the end estate license
warned me uh-huh she is what's gonna
happen every chef that came through and
I didn't listen
right so much Aryan up through them this
isn't that one to place another one the
piercing wall was in between the
waterbed shooter as a two and the
lesbians there par three girlfriend this
girl girlfriend
cool yeah yeah yeah so were you is this
time well yeah when when the piercing
got done just in terms of when you were
dating her where waves or living and all
right so yeah all this is in Phoenix
Arizona she's in Tempe for unic sites
suburb so this is when I'm just started
I'm not getting the pills from Holland
yet it's not got to that magnitude but
I'm getting the pills
la so I'm taking a little cruise over to
LA with me and stuff it's like a road
trip what is that is that like a little
set cars just going across to to free
cars going across me and my mates you
know was that monitor gonna know if I'm
supervising the mission to make sure
maybe they'll have drugs in one car
money another car stuff like that we've
got radar detectors on the cars that
I'll be because then the Mojave does
it's really flat out there you got all
the speed traps so we go on a mission to
LA and we go close up and use these well
on Melrose uh stuff like that is nothing
like so then my girlfriend
we'll call her Desiree she sees a
piercing join right on Melrose bit of a
dodgy bit of a dodgy place Lane so we go
in and because yeah it would do two
piercings upstairs that's crazy
so cleanliness yeah leather sofa sort of
thing kind of honestly but she was so
enthusiastic to get this piercing there
was no talking her out of it right so we
get on the surface you get sick did you
tell you what kind of person she wants
when you go ahead and flip hissing yeah
what might clear when she goes which is
press the legs know what wycliffe
Pierson is a really big one with a woman
with a Clippers hmm like you in the
mouth with a clip with the piercing
right chewing on the Pierson it's a
square feeling
it's it makes life a little bit easier
as well you know I mean listen God
unless you got metal fillings magna
don't know it's just it's all highlights
the area quite nicely Jin Lian makes
life a bit easier Dolman isn't it it's a
pleasant at all decoration yeah yeah
it's a fun thing yeah I've actually seen
a girl with extra decorations down the
lips as well yeah yeah it's cool
like a tattoo so it's not like them so
basically just like several Pierson's
down the lips yeah as well like clink
clink clink clink clink feels modern
it really didn't make a difference to me
but she seemed the [__] love it right
yeah it was just like any other I'm
sorry imagine the woman you were with at
the time had heard similar to this well
yeah it was a lot of piercings going on
back then you know we were even hanging
out with people who were getting up on
unhooks deadly loops in the bodies and
approximately I've seen that [__] I
think Vice have got a documentary about
that yes I think you really need a hobby
when you start doing that sort of [__]
you know what I mean like like just take
up you know that's custom when they do
sort of war and they've got it attached
it was back to the skin just stretches
right now that's what we do just have a
tableau we could do the rollerblade girl
story yeah after the period was gone so
we have Melrose dodgy Pierce enjoying
Twitter we're on the sofa klitz not yeah
because she's New York Italian hmm thick
brown hair got this big Italian brush
right so it gets the trimmers out
wouldn't bother me for the record ladies
just say
well actually no we know that either the
amount story she told anyway sorry first
thing he's got to get the trimmers out
and get rid of the boys deal Russian so
um I'm stood over she's like will you
hold my hand well and go for all this
like yeah then he gets out a felt-tip
pen the x marks the spot you know where
the guns gonna go in
mhm and so she sat there she's crapping
it a little bit now yeah it gets out the
gun I'm holding her hand right this is a
cautionary tale by oh yeah all I hear is
her squeal like a peg jokes like 5 feet
yeah she's got a jetpack on their ass
like a heads gonna hit the ceiling
speaking up what happened once it
haven't gone in straight as she jumped
it had gone in angled at an angle this
is Jose and it gone into the nerve or
something oh yeah she lost her ability
to have a clitoral orgasm and it didn't
come back for over 10 years you fight it
apparently gone she was asking a mom if
there was such a reconstructive surgery
she could get to have her feeling
reintroduced but did eventually come
back after 10 years she's attacked just
to make sure my butt party time all of
my exes had to agree to be in it right
it won't sue me in a publisher and she
said that there was a happy ending to
the clitoral yeah Wow
it's cautionary there is a cautionary
tale yeah yeah Portia nary and they
never get me dick Pierre so although
that like what's that called a Prince
Ali I never be doing that yeah
dude Paul like guys would pull out the
piercings in front of us and stuff one
guy I had appeared to Prince Albert and
when he went to the toilet he pissed up
off the holes yeah yeah it's a bit of a
drag down that is unusual yeah yeah I'm
not letting anyone with a needle
anywhere near my father dick like full
stop did I tell you about my guy in
prison who pierced his dick himself no
no no all right so what gotta fill in
your gurney left one of the
co-defendants was this guy called Joey
crack that's a good man Ronny he was a
really skinny dude well kind of face
shape of an Afghan hound
he was a big-time meth user I can see
him yeah yeah in the picture curfew
laughs you the MEF sauce on him I look
like a big bug dies like if people
wanted to test drugs in a drug
transaction to crack it just crack to
take crap long as like a human drug
testing kit you just get a syringe out
just slam in his neck good right yeah
that's good stuff so so when the Italian
mafia were running stuff where I was
housed they met beefs with the Aryan
Brotherhood guys but they took over and
I would clicked up with the Italians and
they could move people around the jail
and get they could give you like whoever
you want to be you sell me yeah that's
good and so they're like you ever put
some your co-defendants in the same cell
as you and they put Joey crack in with
me as one of them and maybe was often
well he was on enough the drugs but
usually just lively anyway even when he
was high so I was I think that was like
I was writing I'm a little still table
combination in the cell when I'm in a 45
man part it's like once here cells
upstairs one Co cells downstairs there's
a day room there's like
octagon metal tables bolted to the wall
all the racial cliques are downstairs
and so I'm just writing in and then Joey
cracks like yeah I'm gonna pee
macaque that's Friday this is usually
the do do it Wow
I was the [__] you gonna finish your
cocky knee so I've got jewelry he pulls
out this little light metal metal
barfing small Maine month he's like he's
like what I'm a the holes that it's
gonna go through we've got a we've gotta
bend the jewelry so that it's in the
shape that goes through the holes in my
[__] so the jewelry's right so what what
is ferry to do this correctly is that
he's gonna get his [__] out mm-hmm with
the jewelry in the cart now he basically
comes out to the day room holding his
[__] with the jewelry in it his [__]
bloods just coming out of his car and he
says everyone in the dayroom I need help
with my [__] Pierce in the jewelry's
straight and it's really hurting my [__]
right now and it's bleeding I'm gonna
put my [__] where the door closes and
someone's gonna hold it on slowly close
it on my carpet and someone else is
gonna watch the distance and it's
closing this is too hard to make sure my
car doesn't get best idea listen this is
my job this is my job we talk crazy
people like mr. Atwoods yeah yeah
amazing this is this is mod Nick this is
mud so he looks the car sunny slopes
like yeah I'll help
it's not a guy Waldo he came up he found
him we've got this operation going now
what they actually went they're actually
going to do the door thing they're at
their eye
yeah this is why sign up for thousands
of captive audience
hashtag takeoff you walk onto the
balcony waving his red hands dripping
blood from his penis with an intoxicated
look in his eyes look fellas I put a bar
in my [__] because the gut bar straights
ripping my [__] apart so what we're
gonna do fellas is I'm gonna put my cup
between the door and the wall I want
someone to put their fingers in the same
spots and cuz we need to close the door
on my [__] slowly and hopefully the door
will Bend the jewelry yeah but I don't
wants to completely close the door and
crush my [__] so if one of you guys has
your fingers in the same spot we can
judge how far we're gonna close the door
without anyone's fingers I've caught
getting hurt got it
we'll put their fingers in the door and
he'll slowly shut it did in someone
good well I've got seven the rest of me
[__] somehow yeah is the thing though
as the door was closing the jewelry
slipped twice his penis almost got
crushed it was it was hard for me to
watch I was like this is again I thought
you said you want to put your dick in
the door I do but brilliant this will be
a chapter this is going in the movie
yeah this is going in the movie after it
slipped
two times I don't want to Darion was
gasping 22 times a third time it bent
the bar and Joey crowd was relieved he
said that's [__] great doesn't feel
like it's being ripped apart anymore but
feels like he'll want to take a piss
yeah thanks fellas thanks fellas yeah
yeah and everyone just went back to what
they were doing yeah then if you want to
see your [__] again to go downstairs see
your mum and dad
trying it the heaviest door in the house
that's Joey cracks that's a singer mice
yeah Pearson method yeah just because
stories like this the stun gun on the
Contras it's not a [__] in this I mean I
don't come be just I just want to know
about that before we you know if who
begin to round out yes all right this
this segues into Wildmutt as well
because I'm wild about some questions
about well man I've got [__] loads more
stories but we're gonna have to postpone
we'll do a third it man for a par three
I think we'll do it
you bring a kinky sexual situation into
each one's we've covered one perfect bro
litoris so just a little bit of
background on wild man then for the
viewers mmm
well mom was my right-hand guy grew up
with him as a kid he was a couple years
younger than me I hung out with his big
brother and his mates and they were mean
to wild Mike as his big brother led our
guy and he'd make wild man eat dog [__]
so he won joined the gang you got to eat
dog [__] and stuff like that and they
beat the [__] out of him and they did
that he would eat dog [__] and surfing
he was in the gang and then his brother
would beat the SH out of him and this is
one of the reasons we think weilman
became well-known because of this this
treatment that he got from his brother
novice and some other stuff he said he
couldn't even take a wank without his
brother giving him a hit around the head
in house MA so and there was wild woman
as well wasn't his girl oh yeah the
scouts got plenty of stories about the
Wild Ones yeah so oh you the wah wah so
I start to like you know feel sorry for
a wild man getting beaten up I'm hanging
out with him and I'll take him under my
wing a little bit easier two years young
to me it's a big difference isn't at
that age when you're just little
teenagers then all of a sudden he just
starts growing and going like he's 25 26
stone right now he's nas he's pointing
over here and stuff like that and so we
become we become mates and we're just
bonding as young people and stuff on on
the streets of witness and I am telling
him and hami my best - best mates in my
hometown I'm gonna go to America make a
million we got this quarry called Peck
films a tree called the thinking tree
and we sit on this tree and I'm telling
I'm gonna go make and fly you guys over
so I beard you know I went out to
America and left them behind at that
point because I didn't have any money it
took me all those years to make the
money so while my nvidia starts getting
toward the police even in school this
teachers were so scared oh he had him
outside raking the leaves and stuff like
that they didn't want him around and
rocky fought someone had ecstasy and he
tried to rob this person who had ecstasy
and he didn't he did the Chris guy
didn't have act to see you need at
robbing like 10 quid off him and he took
it to the kebab house got done for armed
robbery and yet so he ends up in prison
and try keep up with some National Front
guys his cellmate indoctrinated into all
the prison stuff and so I'm thinking all
right the way to get wild man turned
around get even to American he be it
could be a wrestling you know it's a
positive in Charlie's aggression into
wrestling so did you like wrestling put
Warren well an apartment right next to
the George & dragon British pub in
Phoenix Arizona he'll go over to have a
beer click up with the Brits and he
won't have to roam around he won't be
getting any trouble so I'm working these
long hours and then me and the woman the
waterbed shooter she's tall she's
mixed-race very exotic very pretty she
was formerly Calvin Klein well if she's
got a hundred fifty silver bracelets on
each arm she's very very unusual-looking
so we go to wild man's apartment in one
night it hearts the desert you know you
can hear the crickets chirping and stuff
like that we parked our car and we knock
on the door and the door opens and
there's a little Colombian dude like was
Peter we are on pizza
not was pizza
next I'm like this is Peter's place
where is he next thing you opens the
door it was like six Mexicans and they
let that is the way I'm trying to get in
and they all just pull the guns and
point the guns
we don't want some [__] pizza of
killed it yeah Achille so the Walter
Bishop
she's like just walk up let's just walk
away from slowly backwards to the car
right look at these guys are guns alight
it's cool it's cool you know we'll even
not comments causing any problems huh
I'm [__] it well man just walked
over the road of a big smile on his face
so uh you met my mates remember mates LA
that was Alex he's either head of the
Colombian dealers in this area right
here bursaries Mexican crack dealers you
like to move around a lot rented of my
place gun they're really impressed by
how big a crack rock I could smoke in
one breath the given it meets afraid to
show off so they were the over clients
and so far I've managed to smoke $100
off him on breath Wow this is like no
big deal to him so we like Pete we've
just been nearly pin sharp lava plays
are you making a big deal of this
all right so apartment lasted about I
don't know about 2 or 3 months and he
ended up with a dead body basically
while mom was fascinated by guns a guy
came over demonstrated a gun - well
ma'am yeah his girlfriend had gone over
the rods buy some drugs from the dealers
and Wileman short said you know show me
our guns where we don't have them in
England and the guy was showing him took
his safety off and the gun went off and
shot him in the head yeah I didn't
notice right so I'm back at the stock
broker office news I get a call headline
news someone's been shot in the head
yeah she say the apartment you've read
in him there's police tape all around it
do not cross someone's person I figure
he's been shot so I flew up there I'm in
my rx7
I've got a bit of drugs in the car
laughs what [__] the drugs out the
car go find out if while man's been shot
but I got so paranoid when I got there
cuz of doing drugs and stuff I went away
and I came out later in the day and they
took wild man the police because they
have to test him to see if he'd shot the
dude we have this gunpowder test so they
did that he hadn't shot the deer did let
him go and that was it and that was the
end of that place he wanted to move out
he's having bad dreams and stuff because
the body was on the doorstep where's the
stun gun on the [__] oh yeah yeah
alright so again that's the background
oh well that's right well man wah wah
mouton well what was his bird in
Liverpool right they got to go because
they were the two wells people in my
hometown she's got in a bar fight
smashed a bunch of people's heads in
with mature and put them in hospital
mm-hmm and he was fighting bouncers so
they naturally got together so one day
Wellman's well man tells well woman I'm
going to the shop for a bottle of milk
love and he got on a plane to Arizona
ring and while he was here doing all
this stuff that I've just described he
met we went to this club called the
jungle good info club like a striptease
place and we also went to this other
club which was fully nude mmm so fully
nude dancer was doing the dance that she
thought she was working at both of these
clubs at the jungle and listen this was
her name let's call her we've got
Christina listen that wasn't interesting
yeah let's call it Christian so she's
got all these scars Arlo likes
cigarettes
fire and like she's into all this S&M
and all now I think I mentioned on the
previous podcast that when I went out to
LA and bought ecstasy and brought back
we had an apartment party so Christine
is that this apartment party and
she shows up with some dude some bouts
of dude is like a boyfriend but but
while man and her hitting it off and she
asked the dudes go on make us some food
he goes off and makes us some food and
stuff and they've been discussing about
how they get off on being tasered
because why man just loves to be tasered
it gives him a sexual and a feeling I'm
just happy feeling so she calls him out
and he calls her out and she goes all
right off I can do if you're not gonna
do it right here in front of everybody
so they come to me and they say is
what's gonna happen so I say so
everybody can have your attention please
speech to me is very similar to the time
when you did the the Joe Weller case I
think because that was what they were
originally gonna do was taser each other
on the boilers but they didn't I'm
imagining him in the middle of you in
the middle of this party just going so
everyone who's put the Ferrero Rocher
now these two have both got tasers now
and yeah she's more hardcore than him
right so he's the kolychev around she's
like [__] yeah I'm gonna do right now
front of everybody that's how hardcore I
am great idea yeah so I say ladies and
gentlemen could I get some guys from
English politeness can and I say
Christine's gonna tase her [__] right
now for us all she's gonna demonstrate
this you know if anyone's got a problem
dad just just leave the room everybody
else just want you to be quiet and watch
perfect silence yes do some kind of show
hmm so she just drops the stuff and gets
squats down and it's like those those at
the taser gun thing that's nothing in
between we're a little blue I'm thinking
of cut woman in Batman Returns yeah so
basically she just gets this taser gun
this is
the smile on the face and just that's
going up and down the [__] and you like
the little blue electricity things
little electricity pop things they just
dancing up and down up and down up and
down a [__] and you're just happy with
that everybody was yeah we were all
really impressed cuz everyone who was
pretty hardcore yeah we've never seen
this before for a normal person what
would happen if you got tears ID on the
arm frozen you'd you would piss your
pants yeah you wouldn't enjoy it yeah
you piss your pants so she's that I'm
like you might do it for a little bit
and think all right I got I can't take
this and she's just doing it and doing
and doing and doing it mmm and in the
end she was like almost coming there
Isley all this stuff and wild man's
living well what happened then was the
dude dude is sent off to get the food a
boyfriend come back after does the show
and well I'm a basic says him I'm with
him now thanks for the food and then he
grabs the dudes like what what the [__]
you saying like there's almost a fight
and he grabs some of the spaghetti
meatballs and he puts in his mouth is
there real fun spaghetti meatballs you
come up for us well man whenever a
violent situation is gonna occur his
face gets quite serious and one of his
eyebrows Rises that's all I know when
he's gonna hit someone and that's what
happens one of his eyebrows over now and
the dude just could see this guy's a
psychopath anyway he's still German on
the meatballs yeah and he went looking
on in the corner Gordon yeah that's
pretty serious to take someone else's
girlfriend and then the foodie cooked
for you yeah by that's some men have
little respect for other men when it
comes to ticket yeah but not only that
so am i one of my other big guys took it
back to get a clothes from this place
it's amazing the situations that people
get themselves into isn't it yeah but
then you the thing is you are around
other extremists as well so
was like in your life you might meet the
odd extreme personality type who would
go and get involved in since this was a
congregation of nutjobs was yeah you
know I mean the free some as well with
and one of her over maintenance who the
electric girl the electric girlfriend
and one of her friends it was called
star I could see will recover memories
star was a redhead and she had a lot of
piercings like what you described oh
yeah mmm
she was really hardcore star yeah so
they were quite a handful hmm I guess
that was a everyday sort of thing for
you having threesomes would like this
for sure I mean sure that was still
something that you got into you this is
the beginning when I was getting into
meth and stuff and I'm f you can just go
for hours you know you can really pound
okay
so in the beginning that SP yeah so the
holidays I don't need to talk or people
were attracting hardcore people yeah and
I guess in that kind of errors it's like
a desert things quite extreme anyway
Phoenix coming out of this sort of
lifestyle aw yeah I think men escape it
better than women do generally it feels
like men sort of come out of this whole
thing when they go clean and you get
that like I'll use a wild man back in
the day sort of thing and even if he
doesn't look the way used to
he's got the stories and he's got a bit
of an edge of all women when women have
been wild women they never looked the
same and it wears them down in a
different kind of way I grew war I love
her extreme of all the people who've
died at my mates back then I say 90%
plus men I lost one level one three
weeks ago
hmm one of my good mates out there he
was after pie I was like crazy who's
called the Prophet and he was on xanax
and he passed out on xanax just three
weeks ago banged his head against the
granite table top BAM that was
you night just like that yeah so I think
the women are either able to temper it
more and stop at some point but the men
if they're gonna go off for long they
just keep going men are worse for that
yeah and obviously there's also I think
maybe on a the the expectation of the
way man looks is very different the way
that a woman will look as well and so
you notice it might a woman because
you'd notice scars or whatever whereas
you wouldn't notice cars
I mean if before it I could just get me
like when you see some of these
celebrity girls who'd being on it in
this oh you know and absolutely look and
try yeah yeah well the Taser girl she
had burn marks all over and she she'd
got off on people putting out flames and
cigarettes and stuff like that yeah yeah
which is unusual anything
yeah that's extreme yeah I still know I
do she's on my face okay he's hearing
she's you know she was one that was
legal reasons I had to change our
identity even in the box we can get hold
of a few and she popped up on my
facebook and I don't flame if you yeah
we're in we're in we're in good standing
well sure you good [__]
can you imagine hmm oh come on sue me
I'm thinking to myself I am thinking we
saw I bet you show us to be in something
[__] else I can the imagine star with
a pierced [__] on your face and the
Taser one ride in your car I know I know
they on though and then French kissing
at the same time yeah I could definitely
and this is all happening in your heyday
really this was before the peak of it
all its building up yet
Real Madrid he's in Vegas with the hook
he's got that situation going on yeah
probably lots of yeah and I suppose and
how'd you discourage kids from this oh
you guys do okay fair enough we got the
real [__] my real [__] that stuff that
I've never ever told anybody
and we do it because there's a lot more
stories on these if you could I mean how
long we been going on yeah are you okay
come back again so they met a lot soon
yeah because it's not just about the
stories because I mean I think everyone
loves that the stories but also you got
so many stories that we haven't even got
to the point where we just chop it up to
omean about normalcy read the books are
the books are a key part where can
people go find these books if they're if
they loved half your stories this
insight and party time of my story
they're all on Amazon and then there's
prison time it's our print right now
yeah I'm also doing talks as well I've
got a talk in London November 20th wet
ensure ditch
whereabouts in shortish I'm not exactly
sure it's on my events page on my
website all my torso just saw Sean
Atwood calm yeah all my social media all
my vents everything you can get through
my website and I'm doing two talks in
Manchester in December as well at
texture it's a it's a night club in
Manchester yeah there's a hardcore
prison story in in November 20 Finland
as your ditch Wow okay recommend that
yeah and people can buy tickets yeah
just go on my website events and you can
click through at the links and you go
back to all these as well and I've got a
true-crime books on Amazon Kindle
audiobooks everything I also have some
free audio book codes okay so if any of
you your Gangwon a message me and what
they want to listen to free audio
endemic oh I think
tweet to us unless white media YouTube
me your fingers are since since I
getting on your podcast I'm almost at
ten thousand YouTube subscribers it's
all you it's all your guys
brilliant so if you guys if your files
could help me get over 10,000 because I
can get my certificate from Google yeah
thanks Laurie good and yeah if you've
enjoyed sitting listening to me and
Lawrence chat there Shawn hit the like
button stay subscribe thanks fortune and
will say as there